And you do tuck in your shirts usually right?
You see how I’ve tucked in mine? It’s called a French tuck.
We’re just doing it ever slightly at the front.
Yeah, all you need is a little tuck and you’ve got the comfort of having it tucked.
It’s kind of what I thought I was looking like before.
I’m not trying to be mean, but this is not what you looked like before.
I know you would normally wear this tucked out.
I’m not going to do it all the way.
How do you feel in that?
Good. I feel very European.
Love that.
I’m like the Indian member of Coldplay.
Best compliment you could ever give me.
Alright mate, come on down.
You look so good!
- Those pants and that shirt are awesome.
- You look adorable.
It looks rugged and cool and you’re a mountain man, it makes sense.
[All shouting]
Slick, right?
So, slick.
Super slick.
How do you say it? Like rad.
Come on my love join us.
Oh, she’s a racer.
Love this.
Are you ready?
[all] Yeah.
Ooh. Wow.
Fairy dust. Fairy dust. Fairy dust.
[all] Yeah.
An iconic French tuck.
Yes.
Spin it around.
That Jacket.
[bleep] Yeah, yes.
You are killing it.
Come on, swag.
Ok handsome.
Come on down.
- Oh!
- Yeah!
Handsome, handsome man you.
The way you move and touch your hair, I’m so obsessed with you.
What happens if you take that jacket off…
It’s slick, it’s sophisticated, it’s more mature.
You look amazing.
Oh, I love that jacket.
Yes, daddy.
Alright boys.
Oh my God.
- You look amazing.
- Look how young you look.
This is all him.
We’ve just shown him how to wear it correctly.
You’re going to have every straight man around the world doing a French tuck.
I like it.